the Star Wars universe is growing day by
day with the comics the film's the games
you name it and to be a part of that and
to work with Lucasfilm this is
incredibly exciting so we're really
trying to do a TA is cater to different
areas of the Star Wars universe and
create different game experiences
they're tailor-made for those fans
with stars bottom we wanted to really be
able to bring people into the world of
star wars like never before what excites
me now is bringing in more characters
more planets more environments more eras
and that's why we're super happy to have
both motive studios and criterion
contributing in significant ways
there's no point in making something in
the Star Wars IP if you're just gonna do
what's been done before so it's a
fantastic opportunity for motive to
really tell the world what we're about
and we're gonna bring that the
battlefront which is it's crazy it's
incredible as a studio I promise the
gamers is ultimately gameplay first we
all demand that the game has these huge
wow moments that translates really well
to the Star Wars universe we're gonna
deliver that Star Wars are like fans
have never seen before with Star Wars
galaxy of Heroes we talked a lot about
how we grew up as kids with Star Wars
and we collected toys would bring them
over to a friend's house and we'd set up
these battles where sometimes it was
what we'd seen in the films and
sometimes it was just a random mashup of
stuff that we wanted to play from our
own imagination our aim is to bring in
characters from all the films all the TV
shows and even beyond Star Wars is what
got me into role-playing games in the
first place that storytelling you did as
a kid with your your Star Wars action
figures
with Star Wars The Old Republic the
choices you make the freedom you have
that's really a part of our game and
beyond the Old Republic there are so
many stories that we still want to tell
our goal has always been not to just
sort of make a game that has seven a
Star Wars universe but to really tell an
authentic Star Wars story and that's
actually a hugely different thing how do
you ground the new and unfamiliar in the
familiar you need the guidance of
someone like Doug Chang to show you the
way well the great choice is working
with Amy is she is like a film director
in many ways because she is telling her
story and I'm helping you to realize her
world
yayyyy has some really exciting plans in
the works for the Star Wars portfolio
and what we're doing is bringing in
talent from across the industry and
letting them loose we have completely
different games on the horizon and I
just hope that every fan walks away
going wow I never thought they were
gonna bring my Star Wars fantasy to life
you